no
[Música]
en esta ciudad al oeste de armenia la
comunidad decide y llora a uno de los
niños es la víspera de los acuerdos de
paz con azerbayán samad de 19 años es
una de las últimas víctimas del
conflicto en el alto karabaj
[Música]
pero selling murió como un héroe dio su
vida por nosotros por todas estas
personas que están sentadas aquí
defendió su padre ha cumplido con su
deber todas estas personas lloran y
están en pena porque es una gran pérdida
para nosotros
durante mucho tiempo los decidí una
minoría curda no musulmana fueron
perseguidos por los turcos hoy en día
son alrededor de 40.000 en armenia donde
están bastante bien integrados samat
estaba prestando su servicio militar
cuando fue enviado al frente
el nervio hammer hoy estamos en pena por
estos niños los lloramos a todos como a
nuestros amar y a todos los demás
wolverine am
el costo humano del conflicto es grande
del lado armenio en seis semanas de
combates cayeron más de 2400 soldados en
su mayoría hombres jóvenes y cerca de
100.000 civiles abandonaron sus casas
una parte de los desplazados de karabaj
fue reubicada en los hoteles de ereván
estas dos mujeres jóvenes tenían tres
hermanos entre los combatientes uno de
ellos resultó herido otro perdió la vida
sin duda lo más duro es que haya dejamos
nuestros cementerios allá dejamos la
tumba de nuestro hermano
ni siquiera podríamos ir al entierro de
nuestro hermano no pudimos
pero un día volveremos a nuestra casa
y perdimos una patria y unos hombres
nuestras perdidas son inmensas y nada de
eso será perdonado
una chiner bellum
mucho menos
muertos también múltiples desaparecidos
algunos son prisioneros en azerbayán
otros fallecidos no han sido encontrados
o identificados en la saturada morgue de
ereván muchos cuerpos identificar
destrozados por los bombardeos son
irreconocibles el trabajo de
identificación es eterno en el exterior
las familias se apuran por recuperar los
restos de sus familiares o para ayudar a
identificar los cuerpos
sabemos que está ahí pero donde lo
ignoramos murió al 10 de este mes
entregaron el resultado de la autopsia
del 14 y desde entonces estamos
esperando
sus pueblos sus casas sus bienes sus
familiares los refugiados de alto
karabaj y lo perdieron todo
necesitan de todo comida kits de higiene
también ropa salieron corriendo
alrededor de 80 familias se refugiaron
en este pueblo al oeste de ereván para
huir de los soldados azeríes los turcos
como les dicen aquí yo no tengo techo
tenía dos casas los turcos las quemaron
un ancho y la otra en karim tap
el balance de la guerra todavía es
incierto
hay 4.000 muertos
no no está entonces 2000 muertos no hay
un reporte confirmado 4000 de lo aseguro
hay muchos desaparecidos también muchos
prisioneros y a los prisioneros no los
mantienen con vida los ejecutan
a la tiene cuatro hijos en el frente no
ha vuelto a recibir noticias de dos de
ellos lo único que quiero en este
momento es encontrar a mis hijos esto es
lo único importante para mí después ya
veremos lo que la vida me depara
al audio con sus hijos más jóvenes el
resto de la familia todavía está en qara
bagh al igual que muchos desplazados fue
acogida por una familia de armenios
un animal
están en nuestra casa desde el 3 de
octubre no están muy bien instalados
para dormir no hay lujos pero no nos
falta nada vivimos todos juntos si
nosotros estuviéramos en su lugar ellos
harían lo mismo
smith y lindas
un mes después a la siga sin tener
noticias de sus dos hijos desaparecidos
[Risas]
por su parte enana iván y pudieron
llegar a este van acker pero miles de
desplazados duda en poder volver a ver
sus ciudades natales ahora bajo control
de azerbaiyán
no